我隨便念幾個好不好
我覺得同情應該沒問題
第一題
台灣銀行給所屬各分行
都給所屬對了
考題就這樣出
第二
台灣唐業公司給下行
台北自來學事業處給所屬各營業下行
第四
法務部調查局給法務部上行
這根本就是行政上的長官關係
名稱很清楚
第五題
南投縣給台中市
他可以平行結得出來嗎
當然可以 每一都是地方政府啊
你台中管台中 南投管南投
人家市長跟縣長各自選
當然互動是平行
第六題
教育部給各縣市政府是平行結得出來嗎
教育部只有在教育領域是龍頭可以大升
人家各縣市是管理P事
但除非是各縣市裡面的教育單位對不對
教育部就可以大升
問題是市政府大升什麼
平行
台北市公務局給市政府上行這肯定
消防署給消防局下行
故宮博育院給嘉義教育局
兩個毫無關係固然是平行
很簡單齁
簡單歸簡單來
但有個經驗要傳承一下
你看第三頁面中間
有個常見迷失的釐清
它有一題
內政部給各級警察機關是下行
好這個我只用黑板講
雖然它寫得蠻清楚
這裡講一下喔
他給什麼文字
內政部給新竹縣警察局
好看這
內政部
發函給新竹縣警察局
答案是下行
肯定是下行
但早期有同學
犯傻了
他把他問老師
老師那內
內政部給警察局
內政部跟警察局沒有關係啊
怎麼會是下行呢
他的想法就很直接
考警察的學生
他說我是新竹的警察
啊我就聽
新竹警察局嘛
然後我是
警察
警政業務的龍頭應該是警政署
所以他跟老師的反應是
如果是警政署發文給我新竹警察
我願意認同他是下行嘛
因為我是警察
警察的龍頭就是警政署
對 我是警察
所以他願意相信
警政署給我是下行
OK 我接受那是我長官
按你自己說的
只要不是長官就是平行
既我的長官是警政署
又不是內政部
他又不是我的長官
平什麼下行
想法很可愛
但他忽略一個重點就是
這裡有印的
我直接講就是
這叫越籍行文
叫長官的長官
他卡了一層
他就是腦袋真犯傻
地方上的警察局
確實中間警政署可以管地方上的警察
對吧
可是你要看全名啊
警政署全名叫內政部警政署
所以警政署上面還有個老大叫什麼
叫內政部
所以重點來了
長官的長官
還是長官
他就犯傻到
就隔離一層月景行為都傻掉了
所以一句話很快把它做總結
大哥
長官的長官
當然還是長官啊
總不會你爸爸的爸爸
那還是孫子
那爺爺呢
當然是上下關係
反推
部署的部署
也還是部署
不要中間跳了一層
你就錯誤理解他
就是另一種迷思
這種迷思
剛剛資理行間有聊到
叫越籍行文
理論上
一般行刑機關是會盡量避免越籍行文
因為
你直接叫他做事
中間卡掉這一層
他不知情其實挺尷尬的
有點對他的不尊重
所以通常會
內政務通常如果真的指揮警察
打個電話給署長
署長就會叫他做事
不太會自己打電話給他
通常釋出警局或者很個案的東西
才比較會越擊
也就是反對也是
地方上警察如果狀況當然先跟他講
你不會越過署長
然後跟內政部長報告
這個署長就會抓狂了
你直接跟我長官講現在是怎樣
那就是會搞得他不開心
所以不太會越擊行為
好啦不太會歸不太會
如果你真的遇到了
還是要有能力應對
好了廢話結束
有實際的考題給你寫來
第三頁底下有七題挑戰題
底下都有印答案
但你可以用你的手把答案遮住
自己串串塊
你可以在括號裡面寫上上
平或者下
好交給你
空白時間你先寫我們等一下對答案
好可以來對
還沒寫完 反正有一題來
交通部給各縣政府 答案平行
因為他只有在交通業務對不對
除非給各縣市政府交通局才會是下行
平行喔 第二題
行政院給所屬各機關 下行都給所屬了
第三 內政部給交通部
部長對部對部名稱上就是一字
所以其他的名稱
很可以幫助你 引導你對不對
第四勒
台北市給台北市立中政國中下行
這一題就是月籍行文
通常國中業務是教育局在管
所以市場其實不太會自己跑到國中去
要也是局長陪同或局長去毛
這個就月籍行文
但再怎麼月他還是下行
第五題
考試院給考選部就下行
考選部在考試院底下
然後第六題法務部調查局給法務部上行
台北市對上新北市平行
有沒有都寫對
應該是要都對啦
如果你都對不要覺得你很聰明
因為這真的是偏簡單
錯才真的是有問題
好來一題考題
這題考題我找到最近考的我覺得蠻
值得一聊
好你把它放到第四頁
不急喔
所以我們今天第一次完成的結束題目嘛
那我一樣給你30秒的時間
你好好看題目
我們等下要全一些關鍵詞
你先慢慢看
應該看得差不多
我嘴巴邊講
我們在解這一題的時候
這個當下我們不解多
只解出
發文者跟社文者
因為你抓到發文者
誰發公文給誰
你抓到發文者跟社文者
才有辦法去判斷他的行為系統
所以我們這一題
只做一個功課
找到發文者跟社文者
誰寫公文
誰接受公文
好 我來念
阿雙準備一支筆
我們看一下要不要找到重點來
有見你金融詐騙新高
真的是呢
詐騙這幾年這樣一直辦不下來
手法層出不窮 中老年案變多了
許多被拐騙終身積蓄
出現第一個行政機關
我們圈一下 誰要圈喔
內政部警政署 要圈喔
為了提高詐騙防禦
跟各大金融設立中老年賬戶異常頻繁通報機制
請銀行從事人加強配合審查流程
注意資金異常
預防詐騙多一層機制
確保人民生活在安全
台灣影韓圈在八圈的第二個機關
台灣影韓圈為強化這個機制跟審查流程
也即時更新什麼贓募資金異動的資訊通報系統
所以台影就有通報系統等於更新
請各分行圈起來第三個行政機關
請各分行強化同仁熟悉
所以有三個東西
應該說有三個機關
內政部警政署
台灣銀行
還有各分行
參考以上資料
承辦人李順馨以公務電子郵件發函
發函各分行圈起來
好來了
所以這一題的發文者是誰
我再提問他
所以這一題發文者是內政部警政署嗎
不是
這一題發文者是誰
台灣銀行
雖然說
雖然說事情的起因是警政署先搞
警察署要搞定通報機制
發行給銀行
台銀受理之後呢
強化他的流程對不對
然後跟李順馨說
那個發行給各分行
叫全省各分行好好處理詐騙通報流程
所以是以台銀的立場
行為給各分行
下行啦
台銀的管理階層
發行給各分行
那當然是下行
這麼簡單為什麼我又
去談他的理由在於
那是我們要慢慢上理慢慢進入狀況
如果在節奏很急促的情況底下
初學者很可能這裡就錯了
他可能就寫成
內政部警證署發函給各分行
或者內政部警證署發函給台灣銀行
他如果抓到前面
無論如何他只要
不論發根受
他只要一把內政部警證署提進來了
寫進來這一題幾分
如果是20分大概10分都拿不到
搞砸
一份公文你連發文者跟受文者都寫錯
理論上可以直接給你0分
這個是個錯誤公文
所以我是提醒你
這種錯不要犯
有時候他在冗長的描述案情的過程當中
會有若干個行政機關
如果描述的過程只有兩個行政機關
內政部發案給內政部警政署
剛剛那30秒廢話就消失
我也不會帶這種題目
因為就不會錯嘛
但如果裡面拉扯到很多機關
你最終還是要小心
到底是誰給誰
通常那樣誰給誰的線索
在題目的後半段的可能性比較高
因為前面都在陳述案情
後面他才會比較明快的文字說
請發行給誰請新聞給誰要抓緊這樣就懂齁所以這一題下面的框框也是不用寫字的只是你想做筆記可以做如果你想做筆記可以把它寫個下行你也可以寫台灣銀行給所屬各份行
開心你做筆記
真的沒有
刻意要寫什麼
留個空白處
讓你自由發揮做筆記
可以懂了齁
好再總結一次喔
有時候提文當中會有若干的機關名稱
你一定要有能力在文字堆裡面去理清
到底是誰給誰
錯了就真的是沒得救
我們往旁邊看來
第五頁
第三章
第三章他要聊公文用語
公文用語我節奏要放得更慢
剛剛是行為系統
什麼誰給誰啊行政啊業務關係啊
其實你剛剛的速度這樣推
應該是普遍都會抖
又簡單
但共用語
不是
就多年的經驗就是
很多人在這裡改到同學錯
就到後面其實共用的真的好寫
然後錯的都是共用語
這裡人家用本你怎麼用該
這裡人家用軍你怎麼用大
這真的是沒腳了
那很多人
會以為前面簡單
就覺得這裡也簡單
這裡有一點不簡單
所以要小心
好就是
事情總有輕重緩急跟難易
通常難的我都會先講清楚
你調整你的節奏就要更專注
開始來喔
稱謂語很常出現
用法如以下小標題一套
直接稱謂用語
好我直接幫你寫來
你在那個標題齁
直接稱謂用語
標題旁邊直接把它寫上
你跟我慢慢講
講就兩個字 你跟我
三義主 我只用比較通俗的方式講
其實韓
某種形式就是書信嘛
書信的方式寄給對方叫對方做
現在當然在電子話 不管
他的底蘊是書信 書韓
我想講的是
我們透過書韓書信跟對方溝通的時候
通常會很密集的出現了大量我跟你
就算你剔除書韓 剔除紙本
就單純兩個人面對面的互動的時候
你跟我這個用語會
高密度而頻繁的出現
比如說我現在舉例我打電話給我爸
爸我跟你說
冰箱裡面我早上撒那一條雨
我沒有弄好你幫我怎麼樣
爸我跟你說你幫我怎麼樣
學生對老師講話還是
老師你昨天在回家功課
我什麼回家我沒有超清楚
你自己沒有超好
你媽都說你寫字很潦草
對
日常生活中不論是俗信或者對話
會出現大量的我跟妳
可是你之後有機會接觸公文書
公文裡面你看不到妳跟我
這兩個字出現
你會覺得很怪
比如說交通部發行給內政部
交通部有話跟交通部發行給內政部
交通部有話跟內政部說
應該是會有很多問題對不對
我跟你說你們不明天怎麼樣
我們會派人過去你們就怎麼樣
理論上要出現這種東西
可是Never Ball
沒有
你說 靠行政部門他們不用我跟你
是要怎麼講話
接下來我們可能會花20分鐘30分鐘
就去學是要怎麼講話
行政部門不講你跟我
他們把你跟我換成其他文字
我們現在要花20分鐘去學怎麼轉化地獄
就是你跟我
他們把它變化,那是官方的美角
以我為橋梁,帶你去認識
開始來學
只是這樣講比較好啦,你會發現阿沒什麼,就是我跟你而已
用輕鬆的角度就是我跟你,他們
變化字面而已
接下來東西不用抄
我抄了黑板板書不用抄,只是我用嘴巴講怕不清楚
用黑板比較好呈現
啊
先不抄
好,來,刻意變化顏色,我開始講
注意聽
均
直接講齁
如果這份功文是上型
所謂上型是下級寫給上級
下級怎麼稱呼?
下級機關如何對上我
下級機關給上級機關上型齁
下級機關如何稱呼上級機關
下稱呼上
使用軍這個字
假設你的上級機關是行政院
你就要叫他什麼
軍院
OK 也就是好 隨便舉例
交通部如果發案給行政院
他就要稱行政院叫什麼
我寫一下
我們現在在選你喔
所以交通部這份文書裡面
如果稱呼行政院他發案給行政院嘛
理論上你要叫行政院
行政院你明天撥錢給我
他會把你變成什麼
軍院請軍院明天撥金費給我
不會說請你明天撥金費給我
所以上行等你用軍
你先把這個你先不要記他
你先記上行使用軍
下行因為有上就有下
平行我們最後再教
如果稱呼部署上級稱呼下級
稱呼部署我們就叫他貴步貴矩
全圈這個地方是他機關名稱的最後一個字
也就是行政院如果稱呼內政部
行政院如果發函給內政部
就會叫對方什麼?貴部
所以先把簡單化
對上用君
對下用貴
好
OK齁
對上用君
對下用貴
通常初學者比較會自學的人
比較會爆掉的是平行
他就無法釐清
他說老師
這個怎麼這樣
一樣是平行 怎麼這個用大這個用貴
這個很直接嘛 上行反正你就背了嘛
上行用君 下行用貴 那就背了嘛
他會反應 老師背背平行
為什麼上禮拜那個共有用大
為什麼這裡用貴
平行合理有兩種 幫我們慢
平行有兩種不同的用語 對吧
為什麼 因為這個故意沒有差
回到這裡唷
為什麼平行有兩種用法
因為如黑板提到的 平行有幾種 兩種
它有剛剛好的平
還有不剛好的平
所以你看
既線不一樣
水平跟斜線不一樣
既位階不一樣
名聲上的改動也要不一樣
所以回到這裡
當對方位階比你高的時候
一樣是平行
一樣是平行喔
但對方位階比你高的時候
我們使用打如這裡
我們剛剛先確定的是平行
對不對
可是高雄市長
有沒有比好
你好
這個不用操控看的
確實人家掛街是市長
你掛街是局長
局長的位階有沒有比你大一點
有啊 位階比你大
你當外噴他說
不同公司 確實是不同公司
但是這種行政上的尊重
雖然是不同公司不同轄區
但對方既掛街是市長
你也只是個局長尊重一下
所以回到這裡喔
互相管不到不同公司理論上就干是平行
但給你一個尊重
如果你位階高的話送給你大
彷彿也有他的道理對不對
不然就粗糙啦
你就說我們是平行不怎麼樣
人家是市長你在那邊怎麼樣
難看啊
不是長官但起碼是長輩對不對
尊重一下用大
好
一樣是平行
如果位階比你低的像這個
但你給對方位階比較低對不對
使用很貴
也有可能位階一致的
像這個就一致
所以比你低的用貴
跟你位階一模一樣的用貴
好我們已經拉回這裡
所以放慢囉聽個關鍵詞
原來我們只需要背四個字
君 大 貴 貴
再去推他的核心就是上 平 下
所以我們先不要談這麼多
慢慢來
你先四個字一定要背手
這個就是有時候是理解有時候是背
我們現在先用硬功夫把背下來
君 大 貴 貴
口訣的話
君大貴貴
反推
上評下
就這樣很易妹
你剛剛學上評下有多簡單
理論上你先去理解君大貴貴
他就應該多簡單
他只轉一個簡單的彎而已
我剛剛只是比較全面的解釋
好啦
所以上評下君大貴貴
還有哪裡需要講我來看一下
應該還好
所以你可以發現這兩個功用
下行用櫃
平行位階一致位階第二身
這兩個是重複使用
就通用了
但對上跟對位階高度
他就各自文字切開
好看他有沒有特別難理解地方
應該還好啦
記得打圈圈就是浮動看對方機關名稱櫃行櫃公司就這樣好 那就結束掉然後這個不用寫
因為這個我已經幫你畫在
你看頁面中間那個老師的叮鈴
就是這裡而已
只是這樣用比手畫腳不好懂
這樣比手畫腳比較好懂
我們看課文還是要把它走一下
我們看第五頁
一點點來齁
有隸屬的上對下
下對下用貴
下對上用均
自稱本化底線
或者我寫黑板
就這樣
在文書裡面提到自己的本行
本部本局本院
自稱用本
稱呼對方用均大貴
好了這樣我跟你都出現了
我們剛剛說我們用到我跟你
但公文把它轉為彎對不對
所以公文裡面的我
公文裡面的我一定把它改成什麼
本部
本部打算明年舉行什麼
而不會說我打算明年舉行什麼
請軍院支援什麼
而不會說請你支援什麼
所以公文裡面的我
本你
把它改成軍大貴貴
OK所以其實也沒什麼對不對
就一個小公司嘛
第一點結束掉
第二點我就不念
就是剛剛黑白的東西
第三點要小心
對機關手掌
我們把手掌圈起來
就你對那個個人
慢一點喔
如果你對機關
假設你對行政院叫他軍院
假設你對行政院院長
你要叫他軍長
這裡提到
如果針對手掌個人
用軍長或軍座
你可以拿筆把軍長跟軍座圈一下
然後畫個底線 我就不寫黑板
關鍵詞一樣是軍
是機關用機關名稱
是人用軍長
再來 第四點
機關或手掌對屬員
就是機關發工給他內部員工
或手掌發函給他底下屬員員工
稱對方台端
台端把他畫個底線 難了齁 看文言
台端確實不好處理
所以我記得我有放主事
注釋
無啦
你把往後翻
你翻到第六頁
因為台端偏難
我讓你自己看文字就省得我講的不清楚
好你翻到第六頁的上方
他又把台端做一些比較完整的文字呈現
你先讀一下我先不吵你
好 前面文字我不念
你看那一段重點補充的最後一句
其實很明快的指示
他說共文中用0的地方把它改成台端即可
所以其實台端幹嘛
就是0 就是你的意思嘛
這樣就夠 搞定了齁
往前翻
好 對數也稱台端
我們還是加一下好了
你拿一支笔
再在第四点台端旁边
就直接写个你或写个您都好
写个您或者您
您就是口气比较客气而已
再往下看
第五点
机关对人民称先生女士
对有时候你机关要回函给百姓
男生女生先生女士
然后通称君跟台端
主要是表达不分性别
你跟百姓互动
如果你想刻意这么分清楚性别
就某某先生某某女士
但有時候資訊不足
你也不知道他男生女生
你可以用君這個字
某某君一語帶過
避免性別上你寫錯了
因為台端是您
您本來就不分性別
所以君跟台端不分性別
對團體稱貴
好這我聊一下
他说機關對人民稱先生女生
這個合理
對團體用貴的理由
小心喔
他说政府機關
對團體使用貴的理由在於
政府機關
跟人民团体
它是平行
位皆一致的平行
所以使用贵这是肯定的
刚有强调
政府跟人民一样大
既你说一样大
就是一致
一致就是这个贵
好 再来
第六点
行为数机关
文内同时提起的通称贵机关
这也好解
基本上它的意思是一语带过
就那
它怎么说
若干机关
在公文当中同步出现
你可以用跪机关这样一语带过
因为如果不这么做的理由会导致
假设啦
这里有一件事情
有七个机关都要去承办它
你可以在论述的过程
就七个人办同一件事情嘛
你可以一语带过
请跪机关同时智慧底下的同人
你可以这样一语带过
因为你去反推
如果你不能让对方一语带过
请跪机关一语带过
你就要
假设七个人要做对不对
你七個名稱要寫一次 很累
如果文章當中你要反覆的論述到
你一直寫內政部 拆政部
會累死人 你可以用
回到剛剛四個字沒 簡潛明確
我如果使用櫃機關
就可以讓他們全部都知道
我何苦一一點名
這就跟老師上課很像
全班同學一起舉手
就是一語帶過 全班同學
我也可以這麼無聊
1號舉手 2號舉手 3號舉手 4號舉手
你就不用想過了
你整天搞這個就好了
就類似啦
所以這1到6點就依序解讀完
下面那個丁寧如剛聊到的我就不多說
他旁邊都有舉例嘛 還是謹記
均大貴貴 有大到小
稱呼個人可以用台端
台端是寧不分性別
有時候你看到台端 哇這啥
台端就是你 就是你
再看哪裡需要
我再聊個小天好了
讓你對台端比較有感覺
我早期對台端
因為以前學功文就是這樣學
他一切不難
突然有一天產生興趣
就跟同事聊
同事功文不太行
他看我寫台端
他問這是什麼台端
他不會
我就解釋一下他
他突然
他菜鳥
可是突然提了一個
我始終不曾想過的問題
我瞬間覺得他不菜
他突然說
台端有問題
我說怎樣
你剛剛不是說簡潛明確
因為我教他
確實避免文言 避免使用成語
避免溝通無法理解
你用台端我就會導致無法理解
這樣文言的名字是誰他文言
我突然想對
公文改革
如果台端本是個比較文言的東西
如果他本意是0
你用0或者是你
是不是溝通上更方便
你寫個你
不更簡單易解嗎
百姓更容易懂
那你還堅持用台端
我好像有點臣服不知變通
他這樣講 我有道理
就是一個疙瘩把他在心裡面
當時也解剖了 我就說好像有道理
但我也不知道 手冊印我就跟著用
一到有一天跟另一個公文前輩聊天
聊了幾分鐘的話豁然開朗
反正就演習完了就大家吃東西聊天
我就把這個問題拋出來
然後他的話不是來自何方
但他個人經驗總結
我覺得值得一聽
講一聽
他說教練義屬
台端就是你
當然你也可以客氣一點
把它理解為您
可是我們使用兩件事都不用
在公文裡面
我們使用台端這個詞
好
使用你不是更簡單
幹嘛用台端
那個前輩聊天如以下
他說不可以
你還是用台端
為什麼
因為
不論你或者您都會有文字情緒
我開始有點懂了
因為你這個字有點咄咄逼人
對下可以平行可以
但如果對上你這邊你其實有點不禮貌
然後對您又有點太
太拉低自己身份對不對
或者我們聊天的方式
當我們在聊天的時候
你怎麼你你你你
一次兩次OK
你七次八次我這些
吼吼是怎樣啊
但是反推你又過度客氣
老師您怎樣 您怎樣 您怎樣
我會覺得 哇 屁股不會
對 又會這樣你好像很
對 太做作或什麼樣
它會太鋒利
它會讓你自己太卑微
公文承辦有個邏輯叫不卑不亢
我們是依法行事 我們就事論事
沒有必要過度謙卑
也沒有必要過度的咄咄逼人
它可能會過度咄咄逼人
它可能會過度謙卑
但你反推使用台端
它會消失說了文字情緒
這樣
才會導致他還是被留下來
想想有道理對不對
就避免你公文承辦的過程出現
非必要的情緒色彩
使用台端就
他就是沒有任何情緒
有點像我跟學員互動
學員來討論問題
他如果用你
我會覺得一次兩次
他好像酒會覺得不禮貌對不對
他一直在那邊擰
老師請您喝茶
老師擰呀擦黑板嘛
我的媽呀我的哈太監
但他對我就叫我老師
老師這你的茶水老師黑板要擦碼
他如果使用老師這個詞
就彼此都沒有任何感覺
好啦
只聊天
但無論如何聊天我每次都會聊
因為通常聊完之後學生對台端使用的
就會更果斷跟自信
好了我講完來看範例題
第五頁的下方幾題我陪你念
台灣銀行給所屬各分好往下下行
台中衛生局給司法院
司法院那是五院很大喔
所以他應該屬於這種
不平行的
所以用大院嘛
台中市給台南市都是直轄市
平的不能再平
平也是貴
平的不能再平也是使用貴
來最後一個
台中市給台中市教育局對下
對下一樣使用貴
是啦給你看範例題接下來給你練習一樣有試題一箭頭作答下面有答案把它遮住然後你開始寫一看好我先不吵你
如果你有一點慌不知道怎麼做
請冷靜
你先抓上屏下
他給他是上屏下
然後再回到這裡
他是上屏下的哪一種
你就可以反推出答案
慢慢來喔 把它寫對
自稱我們就不管了 自稱本行這聽過一個面是不會錯的
好 我們要對答案
法務部給行政院上行
叫做軍院
因為法務部是行政院底下八部之一
就稱呼長官美
內政部緊鎮所給內政部
就長官美
所以依他的答案是幹嘛
軍部
嘉義線給雲林線平行
沒有到特別大隊
沒有到特別大隊不要使用大
我們使用櫃
嘉義線給嘉義線衛生局對下水櫃局
所以小心兩個重疊
一樣大的用櫃
小的用櫃
OK嗎
略大的用大
真的是長官的用軍
好
考題完成我們把他往後翻
第六頁
重點補充那個台東我就不重複齁
我們看標題2他要教什麼
間接稱為用語
他旁邊刮給他什麼
所謂間接用語指的是第三人稱
好啦我直接寫在那個第三人稱旁邊我們加一個字
加一個他
這樣就完整了
剛剛我是本
你是軍大貴貴
偶爾會出現第三個機關名稱嗎
那是看怎麼用
所以所謂的間接就是我們開始學他
如果出現必須怎麼做轉變
好來看齁
第一點
對機關團體稱權弦或減弦一再提及給我們改
好讓我直接講他算了
我是本
本部然後發函給軍院
本部軍院
如果提到第三個
他這裡提到什麼
對機關稱權銜
權銜就全民
我舉例
內政部發函給行政院好了
內政部發函給行政院
會叫軍院呢
請軍院跟交通部
交通部他對不對
就使用他完整的名稱交通部
所以他使用權銜名稱
就是不用改的意思
當然有提到
如果一再提到
可以改成什麼?
該
一再提起用該
該的用法還是剛剛那句老話符合堅顯明確
也就是
我在跟行政院對話這份文書裡面
第一次出現交通部
我希望交通部可以配合承辦什麼
但如果底下的對話當中交通部又要出現的話
你可以直接用該部
該部必須於幾月怎麼樣?
該部同時意要怎麼樣?
因為如果你不用該部
就得寫完整叫交通部
如果該部兩個字可以完成的
沒有必要
三個字寫他
還是符合簡簡明確
如果這麼說啦
如果你每次提到第三人跟他
都用權嫌對方一定懂
因為權嫌不可能不懂就全名就出現了
只是他會抵觸簡簡明確
可以簡單的
我們就不打算把他寫多
通常寫多像那種台端寫多的
都有他的歷史淵源或背景才會這樣做
好啦這偏簡單喔再講
所以如果是他
直接用權嫌
一再出現可以用該
這樣就好了
還有哪裡啊
第一點結束支援
它下面都舉例嘛
內政部警證署
第二次你也可以減嫌警證署
一再出現可以用該
就是由長而短
符合減錢明確
然後那個他如果是個人
可以直接稱某某先生或某某君
這個也OK
不過這裡聊個小天
有同學對這裡反應
你再幫我看一下阿拉伯術二
對個人一律稱先生女士或者君
然後你把他往前翻
之前有同學這裡突然卡乾
翻到哪裡
翻到第五頁
你把他往前翻到第五頁
上面的第五頁
第五頁
上方的第五頁
他說老師不對
機關隊人民稱先生女士或通稱君跟台端
他說這裡有台端
然後往後翻
第六頁
對個人稱先生女士獲得GNA
老師這裡少了台端
就跟我說這裡少了台端
我說是你少掉腦筋
你沒來上課
我們剛剛才說台端是什麼
然後這裡再教什麼
對 所以你不要讀書讀它亂掉啦
我們這個小章節在叫他
完全在學他
你把你拉進來亂什麼
所以這裡不會有台端是正常的
都還說什麼肉打字好笑
好啦那就搞定
這個見解只是更好懂而已
就是本名寫出來而已
全弦要一再用該
然後通常啦
其實不太會在
尤其是考試
考試題目都是很簡短的
極少在考試的時候
第三人稱一再的出現
所以我通常給學生建議是
如果第三人出現
你就直接寫全弦就好了
就不要去改動它
因為有些人會說
老師他的減弦是什麼
因為減弦有時候
我都要查一下才知道
反正如果他出現
使用權弦
正確度會比較高
接下來範例題
給你先看
你先看一下
重點我都有框框
我來唸一下題目
依以下訊息某某金控公司人資部門承辦人
我們把人資部門承辦人圈起來
應該是以他為主
依據該公司的計劃我們把依據圈起來
承辦人依據什麼
所以他們公司本來就有這個計劃
行之有年計劃都訂過了
研理課程簽請主管核定
我們把簽請主管核定也可以簽
所以依據某個計劃
他可能要辦課程對不對
請主管是否同意
來
某某金控新招募人員
城市設計
依該公司規劃要安排陪
對確實先進人要陪
而且那確實是人資的事
這一班公務機關就是人事部門的事
協助他們了解公司的核心價值
並提升其專業能力
好 下面有理答你可以看
就當這個承辦人
反正整個方向就是承辦人
要寫一份公文跟主管報告
我們依據
訓練
他說什麼
我們依據培育計畫
最近招募這一批的要開始是
培訓他啦
跟主管說新招人了
依據以往的培訓計畫
我們要開始教育他對吧
我們看文字上怎麼呈現
下面的你答
本公司先進
對
剛好你在寫這篇文書的時候
下面的主子是什麼先不管
也就是
在這篇文書裡面
你打算跟主管報告的過程
你不會提到某某金控公司吧
所以回到自稱用什麼
自稱用本
對 所以這題這樣聊的就是
因為它屬於內部行為
你跟長官報告而已
所以不再會有另一個政府部門
所以不會有他的問題
變成我要處理
所以某某金控公司你不會寫
就是你在文書過程不會寫某某金控公司
打算培育先進人員
你會把它改成本公司
相對合理對吧
同一個公司
那你跟主管在對話
台新金控公司進來招呼
這真的很惹人的對話
就本公司
好啦
所以框解釋提醒你
一個方向自稱用本
或說講難聽一點是警告你
軍大貴貴
還有自稱用本
在實際作答過程當中會不會出現
會出現
就這個要小心
本公司
我聊一下
這也值得一聊
他說某某金控公司
其實
就我受的公文教育
兩種都可以
有沒有再講一次
他的名稱
他說某某金控公司
結果有人聚焦在某某金控公司
自稱用本
為什麼不叫本師
某某金控公司有這個關鍵的師對吧
我這裡用什麼本公司對吧
學生就會來問老師為什麼不值得寫本師
為什麼要寫本公司
其實在手冊裡面
對這個並沒有
我翻手册手册于这个地方没有提到
可能手册比较聚焦于政府机关
政府机关比较不会用什么私这种东西
好啦 来了
但是公文看多会有一般的经验
如果是民间的公私
就非政府部门
通常是用公私 就本公私
但如果是确实的政府部门有私的话
行政部门也有一些名称叫私
行政部门也有一些机关名称有私
什么某某私
會習慣用
私這個字
所以來重點囉
什麼時候用本私
什麼時候用本公私
若是私人的公私
我們傾向習慣上用本公私
公交機關我們習慣上用本私
但是
哪一天
如果你在私人機構上班
然後你寫公文時候使用的本私
他理論上不能算你錯
因為我們剛聊的只是
用語習慣
大家普遍這麼做
所以也就是
本私
跟本公司都可以
但你說老師哪一種比較理想
以我我會選本公司
這樣就懂了
好
後來再講一次
如果有司這個字就有公司
你選本公司跟本司都可以
但如果是民間的話
通常建議用本公司
好所以就框框
但無論如何還是沒有
差很多製程工本
來所以我們你我他
我全部解決